welcome to fox news primetime i am tammy
bruce and tonight joe biden kamala
harris the far left democrats and their
unquestioning allies in the media are
seeing their credibility cratering like
never before their agenda is failing at
home and abroad it's failing from coast
to coast it's failing inside washington
and it's failing all over our major
cities where crime waves are showing no
sign of slowing down where brazen
thieves are on tape committing smash and
grab lootings destroying property
stealing tens of thousands of dollars
worth of merchandise and democrats just
really couldn't but be bothered to care
about any of this and it's getting even
worse by the day for example in the
ritzy pacific palisades it's really
beautiful this is a neighborhood of los
angeles this weekend gunmen reportedly
entered a holiday party at a private
residence
they held guests at gunpoint and
demanded their jewelry and phones it's
like mission impossible and down at
newport beach's south coast plaza last
month gunmen robbed diners at the
restaurants of one of the many
restaurants but one has an outdoor patio
they all got robbed add that to all of
the videos of retail stores being robbed
up and down the golden state from los
angeles to san francisco and after the
murder of a news team's security guard
as they covered a looting out in
northern california one local news
station is reevaluating understandably
live field coverage of major news
stories fearful for their crew safety
while on the scene cara davis and
representative jim jordan join me
shortly to unpack what this means to all
of us now of course this is the natural
consequence of the left's progressive
crime policy like ending cash bail like
softening the punishment for theft and
letting violent offenders back out onto
the street the normalization of property
damage think about that the
normalization of crime more broadly it's
a direct result of progressive rule and
democrat policy but yet there's
something even more nefarious
underscoring all of this because there's
another smash and grab looting you might
not really have heard about recently
it's but it's going on right under our
noses and it's from the inside of the
washington swamp now this looting
doesn't involve smash display cases it
doesn't have a mob scooping up handbags
and kicks no one is lugging out big
screen tvs but don't be fooled what's
happening in washington is more sinister
and just as reckless because the extreme
democrat so-called build back better
far-left spending spree is a quieter and
sneakier form of looting and mass
robbery and the worst part of the
smash-and-grab socialist spending scheme
it's not even against the law for them
so tonight don't be fooled build back
better is washington's version of smash
and grab looting of the american
taxpayer cradle-to-grave entitlements
special interest giveaways laying the
groundwork for more open borders and
mass amnesty it's all aimed at the
destruction of the middle class the
american middle class that's pretty much
us
destroying americans sense of self their
sense of independence their sense of
sovereignty and our sense in general of
prosperity so when it comes to democrats
it's always a one-way street a street
with a dead end of more spending more
bureaucracy more bridges to nowhere you
remember that one and more control over
your everyday life like looters running
off with a stalk of new handbags biden
harris pelosi and schumer and the
ocasio-cortez gang of petulant
progressive children are smashing and
grabbing all they can with this godzilla
of a bill just take a small peek at
what's actually inside this thing
billions for something called tree
equity tax credits for the rich to buy
fancy electric vehicles ramping up the
funding and spying capability of the irs
and haven't we all just been waiting for
that billions for far-left pet projects
under the guise of climate change and of
course laying the groundwork for mass
amnesty like allowing illegal immigrants
to be eligible also for the child tax
credit and the cost don't believe the
funny math fake projections they're all
out there false narratives from the left
joe biden still says it will cost zero
that's the equivalent of aoc insisting
the smash and grab lootings aren't even
happening mark my words the real cost of
this bolshevik spending bonanza is far
greater than the 1.7 trillion you keep
hearing about as though that's already
not too much
penn's wharton school of business
estimates the cost close to actually 4
trillion and the committee for a
responsible federal budget says it could
be even closer to 4.8 trillion and why
are the democrats so hell-bent on
jamming through this litany of far-left
fantasies they do it because they can
just like the looters they see the
writing on the wall they know this is
pelosi's last stand in the majority they
see the devastating polls all they have
left you guys is to inflict more pain on
the american public on us on the middle
class on every single class in this
country on working americans and
everyone else looking forward to a
future with some optimism as some of
kind of some sort of unhinged last
hurrah before reality sets in in 2022
and beyond so they've seen their own
failures they're not blind failures on
inflation failure to address the supply
chain woes which is getting worse
failure in afghanistan failure at the
border and failure on covet where
remember joe biden campaigned on having
a secret plan to shut down the virus
they see this all unfolding even if they
don't want to say it out loud biden's
approval has sunk to a catastrophic 36
percent in the latest trafalgar poll
harris's approval is even lower at a
historic low in the 20s as she sees her
top advisors bolting and her own white
house leaking against her tonight we
will discuss with miranda devine and
mary kissel the impact of harris's
incompetence here at home and even more
frighteningly the confidence she and
biden are giving our enemies abroad
so they see this coming a wave of house
democrats are retiring ahead of the 2020
red wave and even their always loyal
allies in the media mob are getting
pushed out later in the show we will
discuss the political
malevolence of the vax mandates as well
so look this is an excellent example
we've got coming up later too of how we
the people
are exposing the left for what it is
when the creator of the viral twitter
account libs of tick tock joins us for
her first ever television interview i
just love this so the next time we see a
disturbing video of a bunch of brazen
criminals running through a retail store
stealing everything in sight remember
there's a larger dynamic at play what
you're seeing is the embodiment of
everything that the democratic party
stands for destruction division chaos
and crime entitlement and grievance
lawlessness all as the left works to
normalize fear and compliance so what
you're seeing is a microcosm of the
democratic party a microcosm of what
they're doing to the country on an
unprecedented level and scale and pace
and it's why they're becoming more and
more desperate desperate to sell you
more discredited propaganda desperate to
sell you more tickets to their
never-ending fear-porn parades and
desperate to force you into compliance
with their ever-changing never-ending
hysterical mandates and proclamations so
don't ever for a second believe that the
path to prosperity involves giving up
more control of your life don't for a
second believe ever by the premise that
the path to freedom involves doing what
you're told without question and don't
for a second ever think that you have to
downsize your destiny or sacrifice your
dignity
to serve the left's efforts to
fundamentally transform the country from
a thriving global superpower into a
declining socialist nightmare hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else